- Hello, and welcome to Ed
Talks with Khan Academy.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo, the
chief learning officer
here at Khan Academy.
And today I am excited
to welcome Judy Heumann,
who is an international
disability rights activists.
And look forward to talking
to her about her work
and how we can help
learners with disabilities
succeed in the education space.
Before we get started,
I wanna remind you that
Khan Academy is a non-profit
and we are able to continue to do our work
thanks to donations from folks like you.
If you are able to, we
appreciate every dollar
that you are able to give.
If you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you will find an easy ways
to make those donations.
In addition, we want
to thank some companies
who helped us during the COVID-19 crisis
to continue to maintain the
quality content that we offer.
And those include Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly, and
General Motors. Thank you.
Next if you want to listen
to other guests we've had,
or to relisten to this
episode in an audio version,
you can find a podcast
version of our Ed Talks
in homeroom chats under Homeroom
with Sal the, the podcast.
So take a look for that
wherever you get your podcasts.
As I said today, I am excited
to welcome Judy Heumann.
She is an international
disability rights activist.
She's also an author, she's
written more than one book,
but her latest is "Rolling
Warrior: The Incredible,
Sometimes Awkward, True Story
of a Rebel Girl on Wheels
Who Helped Spark a Revolution."
And this is a book even for
kids who are about 10 years old.
So that's a good space.
If you have kids on your holiday lists,
take a look for this option. Welcome Judy.
- Hi, so happy to be with you.
- Thanks for joining us. (indistinct)
- Yeah. I was gonna say,
in addition to that book,
the original book, which came out in 2020
is for adults and it's called,
it's not that there's
anything pornographic in it,
it's just the writing is more for adults.
So it's called "Being
Heumann: An Unrepentant Memoir
of a Disability Rights Activist."
And one of the differences
between this book
and the "Rolling Warrior"
is we had a group of
young people work with us
on the transition from the
adult book to the youth book.
And so you'll see,
not only is the cover different,
the title is different,
the layout is different, the
chapter names are different.
The story is essentially the same,
but it's for a younger reading audience.
And then for all of you
who are Japanese readers,
the Japanese have come out
with a translation of "Being Heumann".
And here it is.
So if any of you are in Japan
or know people in Japan,
same book in Japanese.
I was very happy that
people that I knew in Japan
from the disability community
wanted to translate the book.
And you can get the book
also in Great Britain.
This is their version, same book,
sorry, guys, a little more boring cover,
but same (indistinct)
And if I could also say
I'm one of the people
in an academy nominated
film called "Crip Camp".
And I think "Crip Camp is
a really important film
and it's probably for 10 or 11 year olds
and up and it's R-rated.
So some schools have
not been able to show it
because of that until the
upper grades of high school,
but certainly all of you
should be watching it.
It's a great documentary.
It's won the Peabody
Award and many others.
And it is, as I said, a documentary.
And I think from an
educational perspective,
while it's not talking about pedagogy,
it has a number of people like myself.
We had our disabilities
when we were younger.
And I think it allows you to, in part,
see some of the differences that existed
in the '40s, '50s, '60s, and early '70s,
before there was any
legislation in the United States
that was meaningful and
made it a requirement
that disabled children go to school.
- Excellent.
Well, you just took a whole
lot of my recommendations.
I recommend all those things,
but particularly I found "Crip Camp"
to be an excellent piece of
work and I also recommend it.
So speaking of your
story, let's start there.
Tell us a little bit about how
your experiences growing up
influenced who you are today.
- Well, I was 18 months
old when I had polio
and I learned when I was 36
that a doctor had told my
parents that he recommended
they put me in an
institution when I was two.
And the reason I tell you
I didn't learn about this
till I was way an adult,
was my parents never
wanted me to know this,
which I think was a very
good thing actually,
but they were, they passed away
German-Jewish refugees.
And so for any of you who know the history
under Hitler in the Holocaust,
the first group of people
that they were killing
were disabled people.
And so my parents obviously,
'cause they also lost all their families,
were reconstructing and
starting a new family.
So we were on the road to,
from my parents perspective,
raising me like they intended to raise me
if I didn't have a disability.
But they began to realize that
that wasn't really the case.
I mean, accessibility in the '40s, '50s,
'60s started changing in
Brooklyn, in New York city,
but still not significantly.
I started using a wheelchair.
I use braces and crutches,
but I wasn't really able
to walk independently.
On polio quadriplegic, my
arms are not very strong.
So I wasn't using a motorized wheelchair
'cause they didn't even exist then.
They started slowly coming in in the '60s
and then more in the '70s.
And I did get a motorized
wheelchair in the late '60s
and I've used one ever since.
And we could go back to that,
but for those of you
who work with children
who have physical disabilities,
mobility is something
which is very important.
And
sometimes people look at
using a motorized wheelchair
as something which is not
gonna advance your strength.
But I think the reality
is that we really need
to look at what children need.
And one of the things children
need is to be able to be
as independent as possible
with their friends.
And also, I didn't get
a motorized wheelchair
till my late teens, 2021.
So I had never gone across
the street by myself.
I had never just gone out
and walked around the neighborhood.
I couldn't take a bus,
I couldn't take a chain,
they weren't accessible.
All of those things, from
an educational perspective,
kids beginning as they're getting older
to go across the street
and visit a neighbor.
And as they're getting even older,
taking a bus to go someplace,
being able to go to the
store by themselves.
Those are things I couldn't do by myself.
Now, of course I can.
But I really think when
we think about education,
there's the classroom,
but there is life and
life also does impact.
So when my mother took me to school,
the principal denied me
the right to go to school
because he said I would be a fire hazard.
So this again was before we had
any of these laws in the US.
And so I was home.
I wasn't homeschooled
'cause there wasn't anything
like that at that time.
My mother was teaching me.
And then in the first grade,
the teachers started coming
to the house twice a week,
once for an hour, once
for an hour and a half.
So until the middle of the fourth grade,
I was getting two and a half hours a week
of educational training.
Then I went to segregated
education, special ed classes.
And quite frankly, they
were not comparable
to the same classes for
non-disabled children.
And then I went to college
and wanted to be a teacher,
was denied my teaching license
because in writing, they
said I couldn't walk.
So then I sued the board of education
and the judge remanded the
case back to the board of ed,
who did grant me another medical
and I did get my teaching license
and I taught in New York for three years.
But during all that time, I was learning.
And when you look at "Crip
Camp" and read the book,
you'll get a chance to understand
what many of us were going
through and still go through.
And that is discrimination
that we experience
and what both our families
and we as individuals,
as we're growing older,
what responsibilities we
need to take for ourselves
and how we individually
and more collectively
have been working together,
not only to improve the system,
but also to give ourselves
stability and confidence,
because one of the issues that,
this is not just disability
issue, but race or religion,
which is different or sexual
orientation, whatever,
and disabled people come
from all of those categories.
Black, Asian, indigenous, Latino,
gay, straight, Muslim, whatever.
So I think what's important about where,
for those of you who are
doing anything in education
is really to understand
some of the very important
additional issues that are beneficial
for families and disabled kids,
to be able to get the
kind of support they need.
So that assuming they're
getting a decent education,
they are not fearful of
going out into the world,
getting a job and being competitive.
- Yeah.
That issue of establishing
your own independence
is such a key, both psychological issue
and issue that we all
go through growing up,
but it has different
elements as we're thinking
about learners with disabilities.
When you think about students (indistinct)
Yeah, yeah. Right, right, right.
Yeah.
Thinking about schools
as many of the folks
who are joining us today are
related to either schools
or teaching and elements,
just broadly, how do you think about the,
what are the needs of learners
with disabilities in schools?
What should folks that are
in schools be thinking about
in order to ensure that those students
get that education that they need?
- Well, the word disability is so broad.
And so there isn't one
approach for all kids.
Now, that's also true for
non-disabled children.
So I think what we
really need to understand
is every child is different
and whether or not you have any kids
that are defined as having a
disability, as I was saying,
not all kids learn the same way.
And part of what we're
needing to do is to enable
the teacher to have
knowledge and confidence
that they can look at what
the needs of the child are.
And I do believe we need to
be getting our universities
to be doing a better
job of teaching teachers
and administrators about how
to have effective classes
and for teachers to
have some more knowledge
about the types of needs
that some students identified
with disabilities or not.
I mean, when I taught,
there were no children who were identified
in my three years of teaching
who had disabilities.
On the other hand categorically,
quite a number of them did.
They had things like learning
disabilities or dyslexia
at a time when those words
weren't even known in this system?
I think it's teachers
knowing how to teach reading
'cause that's a very big
issue in younger grades
that I think phonetically
learning is very important
and it's been shown to really
help children learn to read
and also in some cases,
not result in the child
needing additional services,
but if they do at least you know
that you've clearly been
working with the child
and the family to help them
get the kind of supports
that they need.
I think having an
assistant in a classroom,
which may happen if you
have a disabled student,
can be very helpful and trying
to have that assistance,
not just work with the disabled kids,
sometimes it needs to be that way.
But I would say by large,
you want the child to be in the classroom
and be as integrated and
as included as possible.
And I think it's not being afraid,
I think it's really not only
learning about the child,
but learning about the disability
that the child may have
and really be there because you believe
that the child can learn
like the other children in your classroom.
So I think those are all
very important points
and it may mean that you
need to get some literature,
look at some of the
organizations that are out there
that could provide you with assistance.
But I think the most important thing
is that the classrooms of
today, meaning now 2021,
continue to change every year
with the diversity in our schools.
Cultural diversity, language
diversity, food diversity.
I mean, I'll tell you a story.
The second year I was teaching,
the first year I taught special
ed and I was an itinerant,
which meant the teacher
didn't wanna teach a class,
they asked me.
And so I was teaching a myriad of classes.
The second year I had a second grade class
and one day, one of my students
who was a very good student,
I really liked her,
she was having a little rough day.
And her mother would bring
her to school and pick her up.
And so when she came to pick
her up this day, I said,
"Could you please speak to Diana
and just tell her that she
had a little rambunctious day
and just talk to her
about it. No big deal."
The next morning, her mother said to me,
"She will not do that again,
I had her kneel rice for three
hours saying some prayers."
I felt terrible because I had no idea
that, really, I was not
hard with the mother.
It was just like,
I knew mother came here
to (indistinct) school.
Everyday she was really engaged,
so I never said another word.
Those kinds of things
where we need to know more
about the cultures of the families--
- Of the family, yeah.
Yeah, that makes sense.
What are some things that
we can do to, you mentioned,
when the students in the classroom,
we want them to integrate with their peers
and have those interactions
that are so important.
What are things we can
do to work with students
or that students themselves can do
to help make sure that that's happening?
- I mean, first of all,
I think the teacher sets the example.
And if you are setting an example
that this child is not
being distinguished,
they may be getting some assistance,
they may be sitting in a
different place in the classroom,
but it's to allow for the students
to really learn and respect different ways
that children learn.
And I think depending on the age,
younger children really
are pretty into accepting each other.
And if there is any bullying going on,
I think that's something which really
needs to be addressed right away.
And that shouldn't be just because,
typically if somebody is bullying,
they're not just gonna be
bullying the disabled kid.
And I think, we're hearing that
one of the effects of
the COVID period is that
kids are exhibiting more angry behavior
in classrooms than before.
So I think it's just a
mix of what's going on.
Some of the universities in your area
also have teachers who are knowledgeable
about inclusive education.
That's something that you
also may wanna call on.
And I hope that you were
receiving some education in school
about working with students
who have disabilities.
But by large, I think
it's you treat the student
like you treat any other student,
and that sets an example for the class
about what you're expecting
through your leadership.
- Right. Right.
That makes sense.
We have a comment that
came in from Facebook,
from (indistinct), who says,
"I feel we have youth with
invisible disabilities,
things such as anxiety, panic
attacks, social anxiety."
This reminded me of your comments,
especially now it seems like
some of those are there.
"And those can, can go under
the radar in our system.
How do we ensure that we're making sure
we're serving all students
who may need help?"
- I wish I had an answer or a magic wand.
I think your point is very well taken.
And those children have always been there.
But I do think we are seeing
it in a much more extreme way,
there are more students.
And it really is a district
issue, a principal issue,
meaning really looking at social workers
and school psychologists and
others who need to be there.
So that as a teacher,
you can be given some basic skills
on how to be working
with students like this,
who may not be identified
as having a disability.
They may need to be identified
in order to be able to
get appropriate supports,
but not to pull them out of a classroom,
but rather to make sure that they can get
some accommodations that could be helpful.
So, they could be anything
from extended school,
I'm sorry, extended time for testing.
Or I really think some of
the flaws in our system
are now really becoming more apparent,
like not having enough
school social workers
or a school psychologist.
And, if you have time,
it's also getting other teachers
who can really be working
with families and trying to
address some of these issues
from a fiscal perspective
with school boards
and city governments and state government.
So it's--
- So that leads into my next question.
(laughs)
Your history of activism is so impressive.
How do you advise folks
to maybe start getting
into a little bit of advocacy
or activism in their communities?
- First of all, anybody in
education is an activist,
that's the way I feel about it.
You have a commitment to
working in a classroom,
knowing that there's
all kinds of diversity,
families with different income
levels, different needs.
And in some way,
teachers are also a little
social workers, right?
We have lots of responsibilities.
- Yes.
- I think some people will
get active in a union,
will get active in teacher associations.
So for me, the work that
I've done in advocacy
has typically not been, I mean,
I advocate on my own behalf,
but the majority of
the work that I've done
has been collaborating with others
who have similar views and objectives.
And I think that's really
what we're talking about.
Is what do we need to do to ensure
that children in our classrooms
are getting the right education?
And in part, that means
what are we getting?
What do we need as teachers
to be able to be as effective as possible?
And at the end of the day
for disabled children,
my belief is children need to
be in integrated classrooms.
They need to be getting the support
so that they are living
in the world of today.
And that the other students also
see them as valuable
members of the community.
And we have a range of people
with various forms of disabilities.
Some people don't have
a good day every day
and it may be because of their disability
and it may be because of COVID
and they're having more acting out.
I very much respect the
amount of work that goes on
for a teacher,
but really, I think from
an advocacy perspective,
allowing people to have
more of an understanding
of what we believe can be done
and what we need in order to achieve that.
- Fantastic.
So if you did have a magic wand
and we'll get back to that magic wand,
what are one or two things
that you would like to see
changed about either schools
or legislation about schools
or things to improve
on where we are today?
- Well, one is that all
educators, school board members,
administrators, principals, teachers,
believe that all disabled children
can learn and have the right to learn.
And that the education system
has responsibility to teach.
That universities are doing a better job
of training teachers.
Those teachers are equipped
to effectively work in a classroom,
and if they have a child or
two children or three children,
whatever it may be with disabilities,
that they feel confident
and that they get the
support that they need.
But I think still too many universities
are not training general ed
teachers in basic education
to work with children
who have disabilities.
And some universities
are doing better jobs
where they're offering dual degrees
or late childhood and primary education,
but there's still not
enough of that going on.
So in waving my magic wand,
it will be that academics
that are teaching
for training of teachers
really have more knowledge
about effective ways
of inclusive education,
which I also believe really
address issues around race,
because I think what we
were seeing and have seen
for many years now is that the
biases that teachers may have
towards certain populations of kids
may also be resulting
in higher rates of
suspensions and expulsions.
So cultural competency I
think is really difficult.
Honestly, I also think that
salaries need to be raised
so that people like in Finland
and Japan and other countries,
that teachers are earning and respected
for the work that you're all doing.
And I think that's something
that is not as strong
as it needs to be
and I'm really appreciative of the work
that most of you are doing.
- Well.
That is the end of our 30 minutes.
I really appreciated all those thoughts.
Particularly I think
that's an interesting point
about bias, being biased across groups
and thinking about where that is.
Thank you so much for joining us today,
but thank you more for all
of the work you've been doing
in activism for learners
with disabilities.
Look forward to seeing what you do next
and to picking up your most recent book.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you, interpreter.